[Musique]
oui
à première vue rien n'a changé athènes
s'étalent entre le pire et l'acropole
sous le cagnard 5 millions d'habitants
croise toujours les mêmes cohortes de
touristes les embouteillages n'ont rien
perdu de leur vitalité et une charmante
indolence bears la ville
ce jour là tout semble comme avant comme
avant la crise alors alors ce panorama
est un trompe l'oeil comme ce bus qui
débouche quartier colonna q je croyais
trouver atteint l'ampleur et voici qui
s'ils atteignent chante et les voix sont
magnifiques
[Musique]
le
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bel canto
serait t'il descendu sur le pavé mais
qu'est ce qui leur a pris assez soprano
et ses ténors d'aller à la rencontre des
habitants
il faut comprendre
je monte les voir sur leur scène
automobile
cette initiative est très importante
parce que nous traversons en ce moment
une grave crise économique
la situation est catastrophique
plus rien ne va donc c'est bien que dans
une période comme celle là on puisse
amener la musique aux gens on essaie de
donner un peu d'optimisme d'alléger les
souffrances des gens dans cette période
difficile
les solistes et les choeurs de l'opéra
d'athènes offrent leur talent leur élan
et leur joie à une population qui au
fond d'elle-même et groggy
assommé par le poids de la dette leurs
dirigeants les entends fumée depuis des
décennies et un jour voici plus de deux
ans il découvre l'ampleur du sinistre
en octobre 2009 les socialiste le pasok
remporte les élections
leur leader georges papandréou devient
le premier ministre de la grèce
aussitôt il tire la sonnette d'alarmé
son rival de droite l'ancien patron du
pays costas caramanlis à maquiller les
chiffres
le déficit de la grèce est deux fois
plus important qu'annoncé
la dette publique du pays atteint un
niveau abyssal 340 milliards d'euros
sauve qui peut
petros markaris est écrivain de polars
hauteur de scénarii fin observateur de
la société grecque
sa cible la caste politique j'ai
l'habitude de parler essentiellement du
crime économique disant ya crimes
économiques sur la grèce ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer ça je dois vous dire
que tout l'état grec
depuis l'entrée dans l'union européenne
jusqu'à présent a survécu grâce à des
rapports de clientélisme et des rapports
de corruption je ne dis pas que tous les
grecs faisait partie de cette clientèle
ni que tous les grecs étaient corrompus
mais même nom qui ne l'étions pas on l'a
tolérée
parce que pendant cette période tout
allait bien pour nous vous savez c'est
comme quand on prend des drogues
au début tout va bien c'est après que la
destruction arrive c'est à peu près
comme ça que les citoyens grecs ont vécu
comme sous sédatifs en faisant de beaux
rêves
après l'heure du réveil a sonné et se
réveille a été catastrophique
aujourd'hui la grèce doit payer
pas seulement pour la dette mais aussi
pour son insouciance et ses tricheries
les evzones la garde présidentielle
peuvent toujours faire les beaux aux
portes du palais le pays lui est en
lambeaux note à la baisse déficit à la
hausse
le bulletin de santé si mauvais que
l'europe et l'international de la
finance hésitent à se pencher sur le
malade il agonise et les perfusions qui
deux fois déjà ont été posées par le
fonds monétaire international et l'union
européenne ne sont pas parvenus à le
sortir du coma il faut pourtant sauver
la grèce pour se sauver soi-même
alors on paye
mais la grèce doit marcher ou pas
[Musique]
e
en trois ans de récession la population
est au bord de l'asphyxié
[Musique]
la rue ne veut pas mourir son combat pas
un jour sans grève sans manif et ça
bastonne gravement
[Applaudissements]
tous ne se révolte pas ils subissent
comme ici à vaty à 60 km au nord
d'athènes
un millier d'habitants une vie paisible
pas de chômage que du bonheur
c'était dans l'ancien temps dans l'avant
crise et ça paraît si loin aujourd'hui
maria et yanis faisait partie de ces
familles promise à une vie sans encombre
après plusieurs années passées à athènes
il décide de revenir dans le village
natal de marjah lorsqu'elle tombe
enceinte
les parents leur en donnait un terrain
grâce à leurs deux emplois ils ont pu
facilement emprunter pour construire la
maison de leurs rêves
en fait quand on a obtenu l'accord pour
notre crédit
tout allait bien c'est vrai on était
heureux ont gagné pas mal d'argent et on
ne se faisait pas de souci maria la
journaliste a épousé yanis courtier
bancaire en 2007 la maison est en
chantier
quand le journal qui ont plein maria
ferme ses portes en 2010 elle trouve un
job dans la pub six mois plus tard
lagence ferme sans lui avoir versé aucun
salaire en grèce aussi c'est la classe
moyenne qui trinquent la première
aujourd'hui le couple n'a plus que la
paye de yanis pour vivre en ce moment je
gagne 1300 euros nets
il y a deux ans j'en gagnais 2200 et
avec mon salaire il ya trois ans ont
gagné plus de 3000 euros
on a pris un crédit sur 35 ans et on
paye chaque mois à 730 euros à ça il
faut ajouter ce que je dépense pour
aller travailler tous les jours à
athènes
ça revient à 500 euros par mois
du coup on est obligé de puiser dans le
peu d'epargne qui nous reste à ce train
là on n'aura plus rien à noël les
perspectives pas bonne la banque qui
emploie yanis prévoit de baisser encore
les salaires 10 % en moins l'an prochain
l'an dernier où il y a deux ans on
n'imaginait même pas qu'on ne pourrait
plus partir en vacances ou qu'on ne
pourrait plus faire nos courses au
supermarché
ce n'est pas une descente aux enfers
qu'on dit c'est une chute libre et pour
votre crédit vous allez faire comment
ben c'est sûrement notre fille mika qui
finira de le rembourser
et si ça continue comme ça ce seront
peut-être même les enfants de mika qui
paieront on y pense parfois
vous sentez déprimé complètement
moi j'aurais voulu faire un deuxième
enfant et je ne peux pas pas en ce
moment
et en plus je suis là je tourne en rond
et je ne sais pas quoi faire pour aider
ma famille à vaty maria et yanis sont à
la peine
mais c'est tout le village qui a la
gueule de bois les entreprises du coin
ont fait faillite
beaucoup d'habitants se sont retrouvés
au chômage du coup tous les commerces ou
presque ont baissé le rideau en l'espace
d'un an pour maria et sa mère triste
balade dans un village fantôme
[Musique]
imaginez qu'ici c'était le centre il y
avait toujours du monde avec le café la
supérette l'autre magasin là bas le
bistrot d'en face maintenant tout est à
vendre ou à louer
il reste encore une dernière épicerie
dans le village
mais les propriétaires un jeune couple
n'y croit plus
[Musique]
les rayons crient famine
les prix ont augmenté et l'état pour
renflouer ses caisses vient de passer la
tva de 13 à 23%
peut-on vivre avec moins que le minimum
[Musique]
les prix ont augmenté parce que les
charges ont augmenté aussi c'est un
problème pour les commerçants il n'ose
pas tout répercutée sur les prix et nous
on essaye de les soutenir mais ils sont
en difficulté
allez-y dites-leur vas-y roxane raconte
oui tout augmente le loyer l'électricité
l'eau on galère nous aussi avant on
accepter de faire des ardoises et on a
décidé d'arrêter parce que beaucoup de
gens ne sont jamais revenus donc non
seulement on perd des clients mais on
perd aussi l'argent qu'il est notre vrai
assez pour ça alors que vous avez mis
cette note là derrière vous la maison ne
fait pas crédit et comment vous voyez le
futur du village le quoi quel futur
il n'y a pas de futur et pas juste pour
le village vous allez partir à
l'étranger
oui rejoindre son cousin
écoutez ça on revient aux années 60 on
revient n'est pas pour tout le monde
quittait la grèce pour aller travailler
en allemagne en australie
voilà où on en est on va devenir à
nouveau un pays d'émigrer
en grèce le chômage des jeunes dépasse
déjà les 40% et il s'aggrave
soixante dix pour cent d'entre eux
voudraient quitter le pays 68 mille pme
ont été balayés fermé en une année
voici stelios stavridis croix de la
piscine et chantre du libéralisme
un patron dynamique prolixe paternaliste
et très avenant pendant trente ans il
s'est battu pour hisser son entreprise à
la tête du secteur
aujourd'hui sa société prend l'eau c'est
un comble et ils licencient à tour de
bras
il ya des bureaux qui sont à moitié
occupée
et c'est en mêlée c'est le carton n'y a
pas de problème aux plaques
voilà les cartons c'est un signe comme
quoi ça déménage sa réaménage et ici on
avait trois places de travail
le bureau est complètement et et si vous
si vous employez oubli qui travaille
pour une entreprise de piscine c'est
impossible y en a partout il donne avait
115 personnes
elle nous sommes maintenant seulement 35
parce que on construisait en 2008 on a
construit en grèce nous 1190 piscine
dans un nom cette année on va pas
construire plus que 180 200 piscines
alors beaucoup moins de gens des gens
beaucoup moins 10 ans dans les bureaux
est beaucoup moins de 2 des équipes de
construction parce qu'on a beaucoup
moins du travail
c'est clair
idéal c'était avant là aussi en grèce
la construction c'est l'hécatombe la
production a chuté de 80%
stelios considère ses employés comme
c'est protéger ses enfants au même
et pourtant il doit se séparer
c'est un électricien qui avec nous parce
qu'on y adhère
huit ans et demi qu'on a dû licencier la
semaine passée il est là il est là pour
dire au revoir aux amis et cetera
c'est en france à licenciement ça se
passe pas aussi cool
il est comme il est membre de notre
famille on n'a pas assez du travail
il comprend vous avez l'air de prendre
ça
vous revenez voir le patron l'entreprise
je ne veux pas mon patron on a toujours
eu de bonnes relations
et puis je comprends la situation et
surtout j'espère que si ça va mieux il
pourra me reprendre l'année prochaine
est ce que vous touchez une allocation
pour le chômage
oui je vais y avoir droit
et j'espère aussi que je pourrait
rapidement retrouver du travail
mais c'est quoi les autres possibilités
eh bien je me donne un an pour trouver
et si la situation ne s'améliore pas en
grèce
je pense partir en australie allez salut
andreas et surtout ne part pas
l'australien reste ici avec nous pour te
battre
ben oui
[Musique]
visite avec stelios dans ce quartier les
bétonneuses et les grues se sont tus
[Musique]
on n'a pas besoin de cash de casser la
vitre les chantiers semblent pétrifié
les piscines ne sont que des fausses
inachevé et pourtant stelios le
volontariste veut y croire encore je
suis resté je suis c'est la méthode coué
ou pas du tout il faut prendre les
bonnes décisions et avoir la bonne
culture
pourquoi on peut pas avoir la bonne
futur pourquoi aller les sociétés
scandinaves hikma pourquoi peut pas
marcher nous c'est quoi la solution pour
vous il faut voir la réalité il faut
dire la réalité comment il est il faut
mais quand vous dites il faut dire la
réalité comment allez vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui les gens mais il manque
le système politique ne dit pas la
vérité il ne dit pas la réalité
il monte il ya des gens parmi la grève
qui pensent que
l'âge d'or tu peux continuer et vous
avez vos habitudes
d'habitude on va sur les îles je vous
invite à céphalonie on va passer un bon
moment barroso et ont dit aux rappels
vous vous c'est votre problème c'est pas
ça c'est notre problème
[Musique]
pour les grecs tout et d'abord la faute
des politiques
en voici un et pas des moindres le
vice-premier ministre grec numéro deux
du pays
le bras droit de papandréou jeudi quatre
mots par lesquels je suis devenu fameux
dans le débat politique en grèce et même
ô dieu je veux dire pour une grande
partie de la population et ces quatre
mots je vais essayer d'introduire c'est
un nous nous avons gaspillé tous
ensemble c'est la chose qui est
inacceptable parce que très peu de
groupes sociaux reconnaissent leur
participation dans ce qui est notre
problème actuel c'est à dire la faillite
des finances publiques
le problème de la grèce c'est limite à
ça nous sommes pas un pays pauvre nous
sommes un pays où l'état pendant des
années à gaspiller l'argent public en
dépensant plus que ce qu'ils gagnent que
c'est alors pourquoi ce système que
laisse le problème pardon de vous
interrompre le problème c'est que quand
cette vérité vient des dirigeants
politiques alors elle est déjà moins les
glaires que des gens politiques sont
responsables
plus que tout autre d'abord parce que
son cours parce qu'ils sont plus
intelligents pas de faire mal au mal et
en plus parce que jean bénéficier du
système
ce mea culpa omet de dire que les grands
punis dans la sphère ce sont les plus
faibles
victime du gâchis orchestré par les
puissants
exemple le plus spectaculaire de la
dérive grecque
les jeux olympiques d'athènes en 2004
souvenez vous une inauguration en grande
pompe sous l'égide de la présidente du
comité d'organisation du chan à l'angelo
poulos l'épousé de l'un des plus gros
armateur grec
athènes transformer en un chantier digne
des travaux d'hercule des dizaines
d'installations ultramodernes créé de
toutes pièces et en retard monstre dans
la finition des stades
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sept ans après retour sur les
installations olympiques
le mirage des jeux s'est envolé la quasi
totalité des sites est à l'abandon
les amateurs de modélisme en profite les
promeneurs ils font peas et leurs chiens
avec la crise on ressort les dossiers le
chantier des jeux olympiques devaient
coûter 2 milliards d'euros le coût final
serait de 9 milliards selon le
gouvernement mais des experts
indépendants affirment que la facture
aurait elle s'élève à 18 milliards
d'euros
un accident industriel rarement égalé
sur l'oaca le principal site des jeux
fulla farmad a kiss me montre les
éléphants blancs comme disent les grecs
en colère cette jeune cadre commercial
fait partie d'une commission citoyenne
chargé d'éplucher les comptes de cette
gabegie financière
c'est hallucinant c'est hallucinant oui
mais c'est sûr qui est très triste
quel gâchis c'est un énorme gâchis
ce qui est vraiment dommage parce que ça
aurait pu être profitable pour le pays
mais ceux qui ont fait ça n'était
intéressé que par le profit rapide
ils ne se sont pas intéressés à la
presse à savoir comment la grèce
pourrait exploiter ces installations
alors vous avec quelques amis enfin avec
un groupe de gens vous essayez de savoir
ce qu'est devenu l'argent qui
normalement devait financer l'ensemble
des jeux olympiques mais dont une partie
semble-t-il a disparu oui notre but
principal est de découvrir enfin combien
des jeux olympiques ont réellement coûté
qui est mêlé à cette affaire
quelles sont les entreprises qui ont
participé à la construction de toutes
ses installations et quai et surtout de
déterminer si vraiment toutes ces
dépenses étaient justifiées et ilana
palais était temps et alors c'est quoi
votre conclusion
il est certain qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne s'est pas bien passé par exemple
l'aménagement du stade olympique
le budget initial était de 3,1 millions
d'euros son coût final a été de 399
millions
cela veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont
volontairement sous-évalué le coût des
jeux olympiques mais il y en a surtout
un certain nombre qui s'en sont mis
plein les poches
il vous est arrivé à trouver des gens
qui ont profité qui ont mis de l'argent
dans la poche
on m'a la vérité quoi
oui bien sûr que oui vous avez identifié
des gens week-end je ne sais pas si je
peux vous le dire devant la caméra parce
qu'il ya plein de gens connus mêlé à
cette affaire
si jamais personne dit qu'ils trichent
peut pas y avoir de sanction il peut pas
y avoir de jugement donc ça va continuer
or votre groupe
il essaie d'assainir les choses les
premiers responsables c'est le comité
d'organisation des jeux olympiques et
ceux qui ont embauché le comité c'était
qu'ils président du comité olympique
grec
on a un nom jeanne angelo poulos la
présidente du comité d'organisation
c'est pareil qu'il faudrait commencer et
vous par votre action vous espérez que
il va rendre compte de ces malversations
ou pas ça ça va dépendre de comment le
peuple va nous soutenir et aussi des
obstacles qu'on mettra sur notre route
d'arras l'entretien et le gardiennage
des sites olympiques coûte 50 millions
par an aux grecs
aucun responsable n'a été ni inquiétés
ni sanctionné et l'ancienne présidente
du comité d'organisation continue de se
pavaner et pourtant c'est bien à partir
des jeux que les finances publiques
grecques ont vraiment vers ap
ceux qui disent non transforme
régulièrement la place syntagma face au
parlement en un forum de la résistance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
assez de ce système clientéliste et
corrompu
assez de ces mesures de rigueur imposée
par l'europe et le fmi
ils se regroupent sous la bannière des
indignés ce mouvement qui a fait des
émules en espagne en israël
ici pas de leader pas de porte parole
officiel s'est désorganisé le mouvement
se veut citoyen ouvert à tous jeunes et
moins jeunes altermondialistes extrême
gauche patriote pop dissidents et
amateurs de câlins gratuits
voilà
leur slogan changer le système politique
leur bête noire
le libéralisme mondial vous vous
indignez contrepoids
on est indigné mais on n'est pas juste
indigné on a une expression en grec qui
donnerait à peu près ça en français on
en a marre ça veut dire qu'on est arrivé
à nos limites
on n'en peut plus donc on est contre
tout ce modèle de société libérale qu'on
essaye de nous faire passer comme étant
la seule option
alors que ce n'est pas vrai les plus
radicaux refusent la mise sous tutelle
de la grèce par la troïka fmi union
européenne banque centrale européenne
ils réclament l'annulation pure et
simple de la dette
cet homme fait partie du mouvement d'un
pyromane en français je ne paie pas il a
fait 350 km pour distribuer son petit
journal nous croyons que la dette qu'on
nous impute n'est pas une dette réelle
que c'est une dette fabriqués par des
usuriers avec la collaboration des
politiciens de chez nous qui ont volé le
peuple grec
du coup cette dette qu'on nous demande
de payer ne nous concerne pas
le capitalisme aux chiottes et les
banques avec refrain connu
pourtant ce discours gagne du terrain et
l'hostilité affichée contre l'europe
fini par surprendre
leonidas vaty kiotis est économiste
proche des indignés il a écrit un livre
d pto cratie et co réalisé un
documentaire du même nom des mots et des
images pour affirmer qu'il faut effacer
la dette et sortir de l'union européenne
d'accord donc l'union européenne a
favorisé de votre point de vue la dette
grecque
kenshi tout à fait oui l'union
européenne est responsable du niveau que
la dette publique grecque a atteint un
de nos arguments et qu'une fois que la
dette a dépassé 60 % du pib le seuil
prévu par le traité de maastricht
cette dette n'aurait pas dû être accepté
par l'europe c'est à dire qu'elle aurait
dû être considéré tout de suite comme
une dette illégale et non viable une
dette odieuse et la seule et unique
solution qui pourrait résoudre ce
problème économique le problème de la
grèce c'est l'arrêt des paiements et la
suppression si ce n'est de la totalité
de la dette d'au moins une large partie
de celle ci
toute autre solution comme de continuer
à prêter de l'argent à la grèce alors
qu'on sait qu'elle ne peut pas
rembourser
c'est comme d'aller dans le mur c'est se
rapprocher un peu plus de la faillite et
de copines est ce que vous avez envie
vous économistes avec vos amis
d'empêcher cette faillite
au contraire on l'a souhaité nous bien
évidemment on rejette la faillite parce
que nous savons que celui qui subira les
conséquences
sora le peuple grec en tout cas la
grande majorité des citoyens
pourquoi l'état devrait payer alors que
cette dette a un coût social si élevées
pour que la grèce puisse payer ses
créditeurs il faut savoir que la plus
grande partie du budget de l'état grec
sert à payer les intérêts de la dette et
non à payer les salaires ou les
retraites touche au teilleul pour que la
grèce puisse continuer à servir ses
créditeurs elle fermera cette année 1056
écoles et aussi 54 hôpitaux
et pour la première fois dans notre
histoire les enfants des écoles
primaires n'auront plus de livres
gratuits donc la grèce revient aux
années 50 pour rembourser une dette
publique qui n'est pas gérable
c'est pour cela que nous disons qu'elle
ne doit pas être payé
[Musique]
le remède serait t'il pire que le mal
dans les soupes populaires à athènes de
plus en plus de grecs se mélangent aux
immigrés clandestins
la communauté internationale qui vient
d'accorder un deuxième prêt pour sauver
le pays de la faillite a réclamé en
échange des mesures brutales baisse des
salaires certains grecs ont perdu 50% de
leur pouvoir d'achat
suppression de 150000 postes dans la
fonction publique suppression de
nombreuses allocations hausse générale
des taxes et des impôts
comme dans un pays en guerre les civils
se jettent sur les anxiolytiques et les
antidépresseurs les plus fragiles
crac le 10 18 le numéro d'urgence
il est assailli depuis la crise 50 % de
suicide en plus
[Musique]
à l'association climat cas où arrivent
ces appels cinq personnes se relaient 24
heures sur 24 au téléphone parmi eux un
psychiatre qui consultent aussi par
téléconférence
le psy parle avec christos après avoir
perdu son emploi
ce petit entrepreneur des cyclades a
divorcé tenté de se suicider aujourd'hui
il vit sous psychotropes
comment tu te sens par rapport à avant
psychologiquement tu te sens mieux
ces dix derniers jours j'ai beaucoup
mieux dormi c'est mieux car avant je me
réveillais toutes les heures n'est plus
de pensées négatives
toutes mes pensées sont plus positives
toujours pour le mieux
les ravages sont terribles au sein des
familles grecques divorce violences
conjugales adolescents à la dérive
tout ça c'est la faute de la crise
économique sans pouvoir me rendre compte
ça a affecté toute ma vie jusqu'ici tout
roulait bien je n'aurais jamais cru en
arriver là on voit qu'il ya un fort
impact de la crise sur la santé
psychique des grecs le soutien
psychologique nous a permis d'observer
des choses qu'on ne voyait pas avant
les gens qui viennent consulter
aujourd'hui ne serait jamais venue il ya
quelques années ce qui ressort de cela
c'est qu'ils ont perdu la capacité de
rêver les grecs paie très cher la
facture de la rigueur
faut-il pour autant comme le réclament
les indignés refusé de payer la dette
ait quitté l'union européenne
la réponse du vice premier ministre grec
est cinglante
je peux vraiment bien sûr aussi
doublement que jonah de gaulle oui
allez-y ça ce sont des communistes
ce sont des fascistes et se sentent de
cons comment est-ce que cette dette a
été créée parce qu'ils nous ont prêté de
l'argent ils nous ont prêté de l'argent
parce qu'on avait la dette
alors si on repart un peu de la
population eux directement
ils ont déjà pris il commence déjà à
prendre ce coup sur coup sur la tête
il faut dire pour les producteurs
français oui nous savons pas faire
pression sur le syndic n'est ce pas on a
laissé pour la veille cessation de
paiements devant nous oui et on a eu
grâce à la solidarité communautaire est
prêt mais ils ont imposé certaines
conditions
je suis d'accord mais il ya de la
politique sans qu'un prix gourmand qui
applique cette politique est bien connue
qui était désagréable qui est très
difficile de faire passer mais nous
sommes décidés de la mener jusqu'au bout
et il appliquera les ordres venus de
bruxelles entre autres une série de
privatisations
[Musique]
le célèbre pirée le port d'athènes
depuis toujours une fierté pour les
grecs
aujourd'hui le symbole du bradage du
pays la troïka impose un programme de
privatisations de 50 milliards d'euros
la plupart des grandes entreprises
publiques sont concernés le port
commercial du pirée est passée en partie
depuis deux ans aux mains du privé
pire il est livré aux étrangers dans
quelle partie du port du pirée on se
trouve là exactement ici c'est la partie
la plus importante du port c'est ici que
se trouve le principal terminal de
containers desservant toute la grèce et
c'est aussi un point stratégique du
trafic commercial pour toute la
méditerranée
ici à la partie bleue et l'aparté jaune
orange c'est quoi la différence entre
les deux pourquoi ces deux couleurs le
terminal des containers du pirée est
divisé en deux parties le bleu c'est
celui qui a été concédée pour une durée
de 35 ans à une compagnie chinoise
appelée posco
cosco le numéro cinq mondial des
transports pour les chinois la crise
grecque est une aubaine le pire et doit
devenir leur porte d'entrée vers
l'europe
exceptionnellement ils nous ont
accueillis sur leur terminal
leur directeur commercial adjoint ventes
leur efficacité
[Musique]
la durée moyenne de prise en charge d'un
container et de moins de sept minutes
alors qu'avant les camions passaient une
heure voire une heure et demie à faire
la queue en attendant ici seize caméras
scanne les camions et leurs cargaisons
les quais les grues toute
l'infrastructure du port est en train
d'être modernisé le plus important c'est
l'investissement on ne reste pas assis à
attendre les cargos vous voyez ici la
construction d'un nouveau quai ce sera
fini d'ici la fin octobre avec deux ans
d'avancé sur le contrat de concession
chez cosco a déboursé 4 milliards et
demi d'euros pour obtenir la gestion des
deux tiers du port commercial
c'est le plus gros investissement
chinois en europe
inauguré par les premiers ministres grec
et chinois en personne le plus souriant
sur la photo c'est lui le patron de
cosco pour l'europe
le capitaine fuqing ku et compte bien
doubler la capacité d'accueil du pirée
d'ici un an
ça c'est la porte d'entrée du port s'il
ya un embouteillage je le vois tout de
suite et j'appelle immédiatement le
manager pour qui la ronge ça
mettre en place cette efficacité à la
chinoise n'a pas été simple lorsque
cosco est arrivé les dockers du pirée se
sont mis en grève et ont bloqué le port
pendant plusieurs semaines la difficulté
principale pour nous ça a été de changer
un peu les mentalités des gens qui
travaillaient sur le port c'était un peu
le style ottoman comme on dit y avait
pas mal de dessous de table et les
procédures n'étaient pas très claires
au début les grecs nous ont dit cosco
entrer chez vous ils s'inquiétaient car
ils pensaient que beaucoup d'ouvriers
chinois he lé venir pour travailler ici
les dockers craignaient de perdre leur
emploi
mais nous leur avons donné leur chance
et engagé beaucoup d'employés locaux
mais les 500 salariés grecs doivent se
plier aux habitudes maison beaucoup de
sous traitance et d'intérim pas
syndicats et de conventions collectives
on a une grosse direction des ressources
humaines qui s'occupe de toutes les
requêtes du personnel qu'on s'occupe
aussi de leur famille
donc nous ne voyons pas pardon il ne
voit pas de raison pour l'instant de
monter un syndicat
vous avez repris les docker qui
travaillaient ici avant dont les gens
qui étaient employés ici continue à
travailler sur l'autre terminale celui
qui appartient à l'état grec
de l'autre côté du port les grecs sont
toujours aux commandes
le terminal est géré par une société
d'état sur ce bassin là le syndicat des
dockers fait la loi
georgios papa vassiliou sans secrétaire
général a du mal à digérer la cuisine
chinoise
chinese go home c'est vous qui avez
inscrit a écrit ça et oui tout à fait ce
sont des collègues d'ici cela illustre
bien le point de vue de tous les
salariés du port du pirée
il considère que le port peut rester
sous l'autorité grecque et qu'il devrait
rester sous contrôle de l'état
est ce que vous pouvez me dire combien
gagnent dockers ici combien gagne un
docker là bas on le même quand le
travail est à peine un homicide le
salaire mensuel d'un employé avec 20 ans
d'expérience marié avec deux enfants
c'est d'environ 1500 euros là bas les
salaires sont différenciés selon le
statut c'est à dire que cosco a ses
propres employés
mais il travaille aussi avec des sous
traitants des employés à trois vitesses
qui ont d'autres salaires la différence
peut dépasser les 500 euros par mois aux
principales aéronefs tous
c'est à dire que vous avez peur qu'ils
appliquent pour vous les mêmes
conditions de travail c'est exactement
ça et vous savez tout ça ne s'applique
pas seulement à cause qu cela va se
répandre autour de nous
haier est partout et badauds
les grecs redoutent les privatisations
leur pays n'est pas à vendre et le
secteur public compte un million de
personnes
un salarié sur cinq les fonctionnaires
craignent d'être décimée métro ce
markaris souligne l'hypertrophie du
secteur public et est la lgv à la grèce
a créé un système je ne sais pas comment
on dirait ça en français je dirais
nourri par l'état tout le monde
attendait tous de l'état le problème à
mon avis se trouve exactement ici
comment est il possible que les grecs
soit aussi fortement attachés à un état
qui depuis que cette crise a commencé ne
pense qu'à se protéger lui-même
ça reste un mystère pour vos oui mais je
crois que les grecs vont comprendre même
si je ne peux pas prévoir combien de
temps ça va prendre que la première
chose qu'il faudrait faire ce serait de
couper le cordon ombilical avec l'état
maintenant que la touche quel homme
d'affaires en europe confierait à un
manager qui a fait couler son entreprise
la tâche de la ressusciter
aucun
la classe politique est carbonisé l'état
n'a plus rien de providentiel des grecs
commencent à prendre leur destin en main
par petites touches
en attendant c'est bien la famille qui
reste la dernière bouée de sauvetage
la seule qui puisse éviter la noyade
retour à vaty le village où vivent maria
nice ce dimanche ils se rendent en
famille à la messe
après tout si dieu peut donner un coup
de main est ce qu'on peut dire que
finalement la seule chose qui ait pas
changé dans votre vie et en grèce depuis
tous et moi c'est l'église
oui c'est notre espoir on espère que la
vierge et le seigneur vont nous aider
pour que tout s'améliore pour notre
santé notre famille c'est pour ça qu'on
prie enfin nous les jeunes on n'y croit
pas tant que ça mais les anciens essaye
toujours de nous amener à l'église dans
l'espoir que la vierge nous aide à
sortir de la crise
[Musique]
l'église orthodoxe fastueuse
omniprésente ancrée au plus profond de
la culture grecque sa hiérarchie
commence à être montrés du doigt trop
peu solidaires en ces temps de crise
premier propriétaire foncier du pays
elle possède quelques entreprises
prospèrent les peuples les plus
puissants roulent en voitures de luxe et
pourtant
l'église ne payent pas d'impôts en
dehors du pain bénit qu'elle distribue
généreusement elle est plutôt radine
mais aujourd'hui un petit air de metz ça
ne suffit pas la solidarité familiale
c'est plus sûr qu'une bénédiction et les
parents sont les derniers remparts ceux
de maria possède la dernière auberge
encore ouvertes du village mais eux
aussi commencent à fléchir
personne ou presque ce dimanche dans
leur caverne
ça n'a pas l'air d'aller fort ça va pas
se poser
non pas du tout vous regardez depuis un
moment la terrasse qui est vide vide
complètement
oui il y a deux ans sur cette place
j'avais 300 chaises et plein de clients
aujourd'hui il y à peine une
cinquantaine de chaises avant on
employait cinq personnes ici on a dû
licencier tout le monde quand on m'a dit
ok on perdait de l'argent à mai 2000
euros tous les mois dans ce restaurant
ce sont nos économies qu'on investit
pour pouvoir continuer à travailler
alors on va on va manger ici et nous
voilà ça fera déjà quelques clichés
[Musique]
dans la taverne plus jamais de coups de
feu en cuisine mais ils sont tous là à
s'activer pour faire semblant d'exister
même la petite soeur étudiante met la
main à la pâte
ça semble dérisoire pour eux c'est
essentiel est-ce que vous lui donnez de
l'argent quand ils travaillent avec vous
quand on fait des bénéfices
oui on essaie de les aider mais rien
n'est sûr
il n'y a rien de régulier
de toute façon ici on ne gagne plus
assez pour faire vivre à la fois maria
et nous il faut absolument qu'elles
retrouvent du travail
et malheureusement il n'y en a pas est
ce que ça vous aide un peu quand même
oui c'est sûr et surtout on n'a pas
besoin d'acheter de viande mon père nous
en donne ni de fruits ou de légumes tout
ça c'est mon père qui l'achètent pour
nous la famille a servi de secours en
quelque sorte oui on est d'autant qu'on
peut pour entretenir les enfants pour
soutenir notre fille qui fait ses études
à athènes en grèce que savaient les
mamans considèrent qu'elles ont
l'obligation d'aider leurs enfants à vie
et ma mère souffre de cette angoisse
elle ne peut plus nous aider comme elle
nous aider autrefois l'auberge a bien
failli fermer passera-t-elle l'hiver
qu'il semble loin le temps de
l'abondance voilà comment était la place
regardez le monde qu'il y avait
vous aimez bien ce temps là évidemment
de voir notre taverne plein
c'est important pour nous même si ça ne
rapportait pas beaucoup moi je suis
nostalgique je deviens nostalgique quand
je pense à ces soirées de voir la
taverne plein de monde et toute la
famille au travail et aujourd'hui on on
aimerait pouvoir se réjouir de nos
efforts mais malheureusement on ne peut
pas car lorsqu'on regarde autour de nous
y ont voient tous bien toutes ces
entreprises qui ferment et on a peur que
ça nous arrive aussi la terrasse reste
désespérément vide à l'extérieur je suis
le seul client
c'est flippant
tenir résister coûte que coûte les grecs
connaissent leur histoire le prouve
changer les mentalités pourquoi pas si
cela permet de survivre
betty tsaka restoux sociologue et
professeur à l'université d'athènes il
croit l'auteur de ce graffiti aussi je
dirais que depuis deux ans j'ai vu les
grecs mes concitoyens mais aussi moi
même passé par différentes phases
il ya d'abord eu la stupeur le choc
une indignation mais maintenant nous
sommes dans une phase où on réfléchit
sur les forces créatives qui existe dans
ce pays
c'est ce qui me plaît beaucoup de plus
en plus de gens essayent de prendre des
initiatives nouvelles je reprendrai une
formule qu'on entend de plus en plus
souvent et qui dit la crise est une
opportunité
est ce qu'il ya une auto critique sur le
comportement même de la population
grecque
oui c'est le cas chez pas mal de grecs
quai c'est dur d'un côté de se rendre
compte de cela et aussi de l'accepter
mais d'un autre côté ça nous libère dans
mon approche
l'électrochoc crise va-t-il
révolutionner les mentalités de ce pays
où on se la couler douce en fermant les
yeux sur le coulage généralisée prenons
la fraude fiscale un quart de l'activité
économique au moins échappent à l'impôt
un manque à gagner de 40 milliards
d'impôts l'an riposte tardive mais
réelle de l'administration fiscale
la mise à disposition des citoyens d'un
numéro d'appel spécial délation depuis
deux ans et sa balance des noms c'est un
tricheur devient un acte civique
oui monsieur ces points cas de fraude
fiscale
il ne donne pas de facture facture aucun
reçu à personne il ne donne ni neutre ni
facture et ils font du commerce année
les ex parte du grain et d'autre chose
et en plus ils ont deux voitures chacun
et tous les ans achète une nouvelle à
leurs copines
monsieur merci et bonne journée
chaque jour le service de pétrole c'est
maylis reçoit une centaine d'appels de
dénonciation
l'an passé près de vingt mille cas de
fraude ont été traités les conversations
sont parfois surréalistes chef mais je
peux vous poser une question est ce que
les cimetières doivent donner des
factures des cimetières papiers
travaillent normalement oui ils doivent
tant donné à l'eau vous m'écoutez la
réponse c'est oui
logiquement c'est l'amérique que vous
donnez une facture bien sûr la fraude
c'était un sport national la plupart des
gens ne paient pas tous leurs impôts là
où il y avait vraiment le plus de
fraudes c'est chez les travailleurs
indépendants des médecins les avocats
il y en avait beaucoup qui nous
fournissait jamais de factures une
nouvelle loi prévoit une prime aux
délateurs
bonjour elle représente 10% du
redressement voire 25%
si le fraudeur confondues est un
fonctionnaire
quand les gens voient qu'ils payent
leurs impôts et que d'autres les vols en
ne les payant pas ils commencent à
comprendre que ce n'est pas mauvais de
dénoncer les fraudeurs c'est même une
obligation
est ce que vous connaissez leur numéro
de registre fiscal est ce que j'ai l'air
de plaisanter là on est pire que les
taliban ont fait la guerre aux fraudeurs
pour récupérer nos impôts parce qu'on
croit que si on parvient à limiter la
fraude
l'argent va rentrer et comme ça on ne
baissera pas nos salaires
bon ce commando anti fraude compte peu
de soldats et leur équipement reste
artisanale ils remplissent les fiches à
la main ça prend du temps beaucoup de
temps
la lutte anti fraude n'a rapporté que
six milliards d'euros en 2010 l'objectif
fixé dépasser les 9 milliards
[Musique]
sur le fumier de la corruption et de la
fraude quelques fleurs éclosent pourtant
des hauts fonctionnaires courageux et
exemplaire sont bien décidée à nettoyer
les écuries dans la construction par
exemple les trois quarts des habitations
sont illégales le bakchich est roi
margarita kara vassili est une héroïne
une empêcheuse de frauder en rond le
numéro deux du ministère de
l'environnement est un eliot ness en
jupons ces agents ont repéré dans une
zone forestière protéger deux maisons
construites illégalement fait de payer
des amendes des amendes
margarita l'incorruptible qui utilise
tous les outils technologiques pour
débusquer les arnaqueurs cette région on
observe régulièrement par satellite
on a relevé tous les mois et ont comparé
les clichés voilà par exemple l'image
avant et l'image actuelle et on peut
voir le changement puisque cette
construction est apparue en général
quand même temps ça prend entre ça et la
démolition
malheureusement ça prend du temps
le propriétaire de l'une des maisons
s'inquiète de notre présence vient au
contact
la discussion s'engage la mauvaise foi
est de mise c'était le terrain de son
père et toute la maison est illégale et
le dix30 car oui ça me permet de passer
rires vous vous êtes jamais posé la
question de savoir si c'était normal de
construire une maison comme ça sans
aucun permis de construire
ça vous paraissait naturel et borno moi
je ne suis pas au courant de ces lois
j'ai quitté la grèce quand j'avais 13
ans mais si une partie de la maison est
illégal janet malirat mais en partie
seulement
oh pas tout moi ce que je veux c'est
qu'on ne coupe pas la tête
régulariser ces infractions pour
margarita
c'est loin d'être gagné les patrons de
la politique et du business renâcle ses
prises de position contre des élus qui
avaient construit illégalement ont
dérangé en haut lieu
viré par le précédent gouvernement elle
a réintégré son poste à l'arrivée de
papandréou
elle garde sa confiance et sa
détermination ont fait vraiment tout ce
qu'on fait ce groupe jour et nuit sans
moyens sans beaucoup de avec avec
motivation sait déjà c'est très peur je
sais que celle des messages de celles de
psa dans le message fini de rigoler
chiche réplique l'europe et le fmi qui
attendent de voir et s'impatientent
comment demander d'immenses sacrifices à
la population comment rembourser et
faire repartir en même temps l'activité
économique
l'équation paraît insoluble
[Musique]
heureusement dans ce périple où tout un
peuple est mis au piquet j'entends
encore et encore ces notes cristallines
qui disent que la vie doit rester la
plus forte
[Musique]
je prends
bravo aux chanteurs de l'opéra d'athènes
et bon courage aux grecs
[Applaudissements]
celle ci
[Musique]
on quitte
on
vous
[Musique]
bonjour